so the nads finally beat the phillies
last night
six and one the season series before the
start of the double header joe west
paying visits
to each manager a couple of batters have
been hit in the series it could be
knocked that stuff off
last start on the 16th of tampa one run
on four hits over five innings
six strikeouts three walks 88 pitches 56
strikes no decision for austin last
start
no balls two strikes both is into the
wind the o2 on the way
swinging a mess struck him out with a
fastball at 94 miles an hour
boom got on three pitches and it's a
clean one two three top of the first for
austin vault middle of the first
phillies nothing
get your scout report for aranola 5-3
with a 2-9-2 era time to be an ace today
it's great that you get the opening day
start but when the team needs it down
the stretch
they need you to step up like that
you've dominated this team twice and the
pitch to turn
swinging to miss he got it with the
curveball first one of the day and it
was a beauty
so two out nobody on and one so to the
batter lola roxanne kicks 2-1 to soto
swung on
into the into left field moniak going
back reaching up and it's off his glove
and off the wall and soto is on his way
to second
and he'll be in there ahead of the throw
in from oniak on a
drive over the head of the left fielder
and as he was going back i'm thinking
he needs to get back a little quicker
that ball is going to slice back over
his head
and it did it went off his glove now
it's up to the official score
as to how he wants to rule that one so
soto is it second with two out as drubal
cabrera
is the batter line drive and it's over
the glove
of segura harper's throw cut off as
jubal cabrera delivers
again that's his sixth rbi in the last
two games plus one at bat
and the nats are on top drubal cabrera
professional hitter professional
baseball player plug him in anywhere on
defense he's gonna make the play
get him in an rbi situation he turns up
the volume
last year 18 home runs 91 driven in john
gomes heading back to first with two
away and victor robles coming up
sets up away here's the o2 swinging a
miss fastball got him
and there's the second strike out of the
game for aaron nolda
no runs a leadoff hit a man left after
two complete
phillies a pair of hits here in the
third have a scoring chance with bryce
harper coming up
both ready he kicks the 3-2 down and in
ball four and he walked him and that's
the first walk
for bryce harper in the last four games
including today
two infielders per side here's the 0-1
swinging a ground ball hit to short turn
her down when he has it flips to garcia
at second for the force play on harper
and vote survives bases loaded in the
top of the third
so a good start to the inning with the
lead off double we'll see if they can
get him around and get him in
as here's turner nola fires swinging a
long drive down the left field line
toward the corner and this one is down
and one hop off the fence
headed to the plate stevenson the throw
towards second turner going there the
slide and he is
safe and a booming double for turner
scoring stevenson
and i'm back to back doubles the
nationals now lead it two to nothing
14th double the year a ringing double so
two hard hit baseballs in a row
the third inning had to turn it on a
little bit here at the end
and yeah it's only the third inning and
juan soto is not going to hit
first base open nobody out so that's the
first out of the inning and now runners
are at first and third
for brock holt ground ball and it's off
jay bruce down into the corner
three-nothing nets heading for third
cabrera
and now the ball gets away from bryce
harper for another run
this is unraveling for the phillies
right before their eyes it's four
nothing washington look it would have
been a tough turn double play if bruce
comes up with it but
yeah it under his glove over the
nationals leading four nothing luis
garcia will try to
deliver run number five tap her left
side
this is going to be interesting he is
safe and it's five nothing perfect
placement on that ball
slightly playing the pull side for dede
and young legs of luis garcia beats it
that'll bring up gene segura the balls
in one strike to segura
that one's whacked out to left field
it's pretty deep going back on it is
soto and
it is gone a home run for segora his
seventh of the year and the phillies are
finally on the board here in the fourth
inning
and it's now a five to one washington
lead 93 mile an hour fastball right in
the middle of play
short quick swing there was no trying to
add anything to that
outfield is shallow for gregorius
popped up trey turner's got to come in
for this one
austin both six innings the phillies
with
no answer for austin votes today one out
away from throwing a
seven inning complete game line drive
and harrison's got it
complete game for austin voth
it's the 28th complete game in major
league baseball this season
and he's the 25th different pitcher to
do it